Learner A4: السلام عليكم يا شباب انتو عايز أقول لك.
Learner A3: فرنش.
Learner A4: ألو.
Learner A3: ايوا هم سمعتوا.
Learner A4: اهلا وسهلا. اهلا وسهلا.
Learner A3: لا والله.
Learner A4: ا.
Learner A4: الحمد لله منورين والله.
Learner A3: تدريج.
Learner A4: لا الحمد لله بتاعك بص ابهدلني بهدلني.
Learner A3: بس ليه.
Learner A4: والله إنت شغال البتاعه.
Learner A3: الهم.
Learner A4: أما قعدت تغير قعدت تغير.
Learner A3: ألو.
Learner A4: أنا غيرت الكود بتاعي.
Learner A3: المدن.
Learner A4: غيرت. لا ما انت علشان أغير الموديل يعني أنا أغير ال كود بتاعي أنا خليتها في بتاعتي وخلاص.
Learner A3: كيف حالك؟ ماشي.
Learner A4: يعني هو يعني دلوقتي لما يجي يرن.
Learner A3: تصبح.
Learner A4: شغال. تمام لو مش شغال حيشتغل بقى اللي أنا حطيت.
Learner A3: طيب انت عارف اني اف بي اي.
Learner A4: أنا جبت تقريبا هو في شوي شغالين بالديموناي شوية بوبن راوتر كده يعني.
Learner A3: فرنش.
Learner A4: بس يعني.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: عشان مظبوط.
Learner A3: لي بس.
Learner A4: ما أنا بقولك.
Learner A3: إنف.
Learner A3: وكان شغال يعني عايز أقول لك حلاوة.
Learner A4: ما هو كان حلاوة أنا برضه على فكرة نفس الكلام.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: الأولى بتاعته هتنفع، وهذا مش هتنفع.
Learner A4: مع غليان.
Learner A3: نحطه في.
Learner A4: ما هو المشكله ان هي تريد الفيديو الذي يطلع
Learner A4: يعني ياخذ راحته فاهم ما يزودش عن 4 دقايق وما يقلش عن الدقيقة ونص فاهم.
Learner A3: طبعا.
Learner A3: محترمة يعني.
Learner A4: محترمه.
Learner A3: كبيرة جدا.
Learner A4: بالضبط.
Learner A3: لا.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: وبعدين يجي 1 بياخد وبعدين يرجع.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: اتنطط ما بين الايزن.
Learner A3: ميزة كبيرة جدا.
Learner A3: كثير جدا.
Learner A4: دي حقيقة.
Learner A3: لا مش عارف.
Learner A4: ما ما بعتلها كده امبارح.
Learner A3: لا فندق.
Learner A4: ما أنا بعثت لها مبارح قالت لي شوفوا طيب لو ممكن تجمعوا وتاخدوا إي بي آي بفلوس يعني
Learner A4: وابعت لي.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: رايسنغ،
Learner A3: وبعتهولنا يعني.
Learner A4: ما والله ما أعرفش يعني بسنج وهبعتلك.
Learner A3: حاجة لأن دي شركتهم أو دي انتيرت.
Learner A4: ما هي المفروض يعني.
Learner A3: تشايع.
Learner A4: إحنا مترددين خلي بالك أه.
Learner A4: بقولك إحنا متراقبين ما اتخبطش بالكلام.
Learner A3: لا يا ابني والله لا لا والله لا ينفع اقول حاجه لا استطيع ان اقولها. امام ان انا اتكلم عنهم فاهم قصدي فلا تقوى. هكذا.
Learner A4: يا عم أنا عارف أنا.
Learner A3: انا اريد ان اقول لك اننا اكبر من فرح.
Learner A4: فرنش.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A3: الآخر.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله.
Learner A3: تمام انا مش عايز صغير والله.
Learner A4: يا عمو والله أنا مش قصدي كده برضه أنا مش قصدي كده والله أنا بقدر بس.
Learner A3: هذا.
Learner A4: أبدا.
Learner A3: حناخذ من الانترنت مش فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: ما يعني هو أنا كده ما عنديش مشكلة يعني هو أنا عاجبني الصوت أيوة.
Learner A3: شو رأيك.
Learner A4: أنا دخلت فكرة جديدة.
Learner A3: عجباني جدا بصراحة.
Learner A3: معلش عشان.
Learner A4: الكلام.
Learner A4: أولا.
Learner A3: محتاجين محترمة يعني عشان محتاجين كثير قوي عشان نشتغل بيها.
Learner A3: لكن.
Learner A4: عايزين نعمل حاجة.
Learner A3: قلي.
Learner A4: اسامة سامعني أسامة، هل تسمعني.
Learner A6: كما سمعته تماما.
Learner A4: طب بص عشان هي القعدة المرة ده تبقى انا وانت وانا ومع بعضينا بقى.
Learner A6: بسلامة.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: الله.
Learner A4: بص معلش على آخر.
Learner A3: مرسي.
Learner A4: إحنا كلنا مع بعض بس حنعمل على المرة اللي فاتت عشان نقول الكومنت اللي هي قالت.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: تمام تمام خليني افتح اللي انت عملته ولا تبعد بعدها.
Learner A4: صباح النور.
Learner A6: معلش فصلت مبارح في النص أساسا. ما عرفتش اكمل وفصل النت مني.
Learner A6: خرجت من النص معلش.
Learner A4: يا عمي سهلا عادي انتو شايفين حاجة دلوقتي شايفين
Learner A4: أوتز.
Learner A4: ومين.
Learner A4: ، انا دخلت على طيب ماشي بصي.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: خلينا بس ناقل صوت.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: والله البارح الحمد لله ما فيش اي صوت بص
Learner A4: هو عجبها انت سمعت الكلام صح؟
Learner A6: هو في الأول كله تمام.
Learner A4: ماشي علامة.
Learner A6: اللي ورا صح.
Learner A4: لأن مش من الورا هي عايزة حاجة هي عايزة حاجة زي اللي كانت معمولة فين في الفيديو.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: خليني سني كدا اجيبهولك برضه.
Learner A4: هي عايزة الفيديو إن ده هو ده اللي عايزاه في افريقيا.
Learner A4: حاجة زي كده تمام يعني بالطريقة دي على الاتش تي ام ال تمام يعني مثلا زي كده
Learner A4: وبيعدي كل وحدة عندك وعندك يعني عايزة هي قالت كذا كومنت معلش يا جماعة كويس الكلام بيتكعب شوية
Learner A4: أول كومنت خالص هي ليكو
Learner A4: اللي انت عندك هنا الديزاين اللي ورا
Learner A4: هي عايزة بلانك زي إيه زي اللي كان هنا بس
Learner A4: هي عايزاه حاجة كده أول حاجة خالص.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: قالت لك هنبتدي عايزة دي الداخلة الأولى فإحنا ممكن نعمل تمام هنثبت ال لوغو بتاعت برند
Learner A4: اللي هنا ده ممكن نعملها عادي على حسب التوبيك يبقى طالع هنا
Learner A4: يعني إحنا ممكن نثبت التمثيل ده كله بس يعني براحتكو عادي تمام.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: ده كومنت اللي هي قالته أول حاجة خالص ثاني كومنت الخط ده برضه أو الشريط ده تمام
Learner A4: ما هي عايزة حاجة وحدة حاجة وحدة خالص كأنك بتشرح كده تمام
Learner A4: تمام عندنا هنا بعد كده قالت إيه طبعا احنا مش ما عندناش اشخاص حيتكلموا الحوار كلو شغال
Learner A4: تمام قالتلك من اول هنا عايزه الحاجة تنزل وحده عجب بنفس.
Learner A4: مظلم.
Learner A4: ا.
Learner A4: إيه.
Learner A4: بقول الكلام حيبقى تكساس سويسرا.
Learner A4: أظن ولا
Learner A4: هو إحنا مش محتاجين نعمل كمان فهو كفاية قوي
Learner A4: هو الكلام. ده أنا براجع عليه لأن ده كان عمر وبرضه لأسامة علشان ده المفروض يعني هزبطه انا وأسامة
Learner A4: ومنه برضو يعني بقى انت ما حضرتش المتينغ بتاع مبارح صح؟
Learner A4: ما حضرتش للأسف كان عندي.
Learner A4: أنا بقولك بقى إيه اللي حصل مبارح هي قالت كومنت علي
Learner A4: يعني دا كان المين توبك تمام.
Learner A4: لا أنت بتقولي حاجة أنا وأسامة.
Learner A4: أنا أنا سامع حنبقى ماسكين الحتة دي يعني بعد ما انتو تخلصوا خالص يعني الشغل بتاع وكده المفروض أنا أسامة حنزبط
Learner A4: بحيث ان احنا ناخذ كل الكلام اللي حصل في نطلعه على طول يترندر ويحصله أنيميشن ويبقى داون لودو في
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: طيب.
Learner A4: يعني أنا مثلا حتى بتاعتي واقفة عند الستج بتاعتك
Learner A4: ما دام ما بيحصلش حاجة بعدها ما فيش حاجة تمام معايا أسامة تمام.
Learner A6: معكن تمام.
Learner A4: حلو أوي اللي هي قالته برضو هي عايزة حاجة شبه دقة.
Learner A4: تمام ثاني حاجة.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: نفتح اللي كنت عامله أنا بالنسبة لي عامله ده كثير بس هي كان لها وجهة نظر.
Learner A3: لا علينا اقاطعك ثانية وحدة معليش.
Learner A4: تمام ما فيش مشكلة.
Learner A3: كلام مهم شوية وأنا للأسف، في الشارع
Learner A3: ستأذنك لو تبقى تعمل هكذا وتبعتهالنا على سيركل.
Learner A4: الله.
Learner A4: الدنيا بس الأول.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A3: معاك بس انا حاسس انا يعني ممكن اسقط حاجه وانا بركب او.
Learner A4: طيب أهلا وسهلا.
Learner A3: في النوتس حتى يبقى زي الفل.
Learner A4: ماشي بس سؤال ممكن يبقى في غنى عن الكلام ده انت حضرت الميتينج اللي فات صح؟
Learner A3: بلانينغ.
Learner A4: ال ميتينغ اللي فات الميتين اللي فات بتاع مبارح.
Learner A4: امبارح.
Learner A3: لا، لم احضرت مبارح الآن؟
Learner A4: حضرتش.
Learner A3: يعني المعاد تغير فوجدت ان انا ببص.
Learner A4: طيب.
Learner A3: بعدما.
Learner A4: ما هو انت التذكرة بتاعتك بتاعة الاسبوع ده.
Learner A3: ان انا هاف فايناليزنت اللي أنا شغال به وسأشوف الدنيا مع عمر خالد.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A3: لا.
Learner A4: بعته.
Learner A3: إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: سيد منجمي.
Learner A3: لو هو محتاج يعني محتاج يعدل شيء عندي او هكذا.
Learner A4: خلاص ماشي طيب الكلام اللي انا بقوله حاليا ده ليس مهم قوي بالنسبه لك ال.
Learner A3: الساحة كدا.
Learner A4: أنت السيج بتاعتك يعني إحنا السيج اللي بعدكوا.
Learner A3: ما انا اتكلم انت تتكلم الان صح؟
Learner A4: حفهمك على حاجة.
Learner A3: مع.
Learner A4: تمام جينا هنا ده المفروض ال يو اي اللي انا عملتو تمام.
Learner A3: تمام.
Learner A4: عملنا. تمام احنا عندنا المفروض في الاول خالص كانوا 8 فيزو.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: الثلاثة دول الندى عمل دروب للبروجرام اصلا
Learner A4: يوسف بصراحة مش عارف الشغل بتاعه مش عارف
Learner A4: المهم يعني اللي هو بيوقف عند عمر
Learner A4: تمام عمر بيعمل إيه بيعمل للأسف.
Learner A3: أيوة.
Learner A4: وأنا عملت إيه مكان أحمد هو المفروض دلوقتي.
Learner A3: ما يصير.
Learner A4: اليمن ماشي عامة يعني هو المفروض اللي هو كان بيرن لحد الآخر لحد هنا تمام.
Learner A6: ب.
Learner A4: تو ون تو ثري معرفش وبتستلم للي بعده اللي بعده بيستلم عندك بيخلص فين هنا.
Learner A3: تمام تمام.
Learner A4: تمام المهمة أو هي لأسامة بس إحنا الاثنين يعني اللي هو حياخد.
Learner A3: على.
Learner A4: ده حيبدأ يعمل حاجة شبه الكلام ده بناء على اللي دخلت.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A3: مرسي اللي هي قالت لي.
Learner A4: اللي إحنا عملناها اللي عدت دي كلها يعني.
Learner A6: اللي عم تطلع.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: ده كده.
Learner A6: ويأخذ نفسه اللي هو السكريبت بقى أو السعر اللي هو.
Learner A4: مضبوط.
Learner A6: أو ماخد التنين دول وهديل نفسها ما تعملش إنت أسيد من عندك.
Learner A4: بالظبط.
Learner A6: طب ماشي بإذن العيد إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: بس في الحقيقة اللي أنا التوفيك بتاع مبارح كان المندي في الكلام ده لأن يا مصطفى انت ما دخلتش وبرضه عمر ما دخلش، فهو مكنش، في نعاس كتير.
Learner A6: هو في.
Learner A4: أيوا معاك.
Learner A6: أساسا إن هي بتتكلم في حاجة واللي حاجة ثانية يعني أنا اللي جاي. لي أنا محتاج إني أعمل حاليا تيم ليتس
Learner A6: جاهزة تماما.
Learner A6: يعني هو محتاج أعمله. أعمل إني أنا أعمل على الأقل فور ديستان لي أو تنبليتس
Learner A6: دولت اللي هم يعتبر بعملهم بجن جاكو.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: بس ومن الصين إكستنشن.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A6: عشان كلود فور يفري.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A6: كل.
Learner A4: ما هو المشكلة في إيه المشكلة إن التاسكت بتاعتك المرة كان قصدها بيها الكلام ده كان قصدها بيها التاسك اللي أنا بقوله دلوقتي ده يعني هي عايزة شايف الشغل اللي انت عملته ده.
Learner A6: فهمتوا.
Learner A4: نعدل عليه الكومنت اللي هي قالتها وتبقى اللي داخلة اللي إحنا عاملينها يعني استخدمت
Learner A4: هي صح هو انا كان عندي سؤال هو انت دلوقتي اللي انت استخدمتها دي كانت ماشية بنفس التروكتور اللي احنا ماسحين بيه.
Learner A6: نفس أساسا بكل حاجة. أنا كل اللي بعمله إن إنت حتاخدها مش انت.
Learner A4: أنت.
Learner A6: في الآخر. أنت بيخرج من الصين عندك دلوقتي صح؟
Learner A6: هو حياخذ حياخذ الجسر وحيكمل شغله عادي كله.
Learner A4: لأن أنا امبارح ما طلعليش حوست كل أوت بوتس كانت حاييم عرفت.
Learner A6: انت لما جربت جربت إزاي بالزبط.
Learner A4: عملتوا بروجينز بتاعتك بس.
Learner A4: يعني انت شايف اللي هو.
Learner A4: كمل كم ده.
Learner A4: ماشي قولوا عبال ما أنا.
Learner A4: الله هو بتقول في الآخر آخر حاجة مكتوب في توست كوتا إز نوت غود.
Learner A4: أهلا وسهلا.
Learner A6: ده هي بعتك دلوقتي.
Learner A4: ر.
Learner A4: لأ؟ فل على إرتياب التاسبورت.
Learner A4: مصطفى باهي تو ثوز كواليتي أوف ذي فيسولز أند سي هاوي يو إينتيد ماي في ثير إز إيشو إن ذي إماراتيشن أوف ذم تو
Learner A4: كوتر إز نوت غول.
Learner A4: تقريبا.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A4: ما هي ما هي من ضمن خلينا طب نعمل ريكاب للكلام؟ تمام.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: نرجع للكلام اللي هي قالته يبقى كده أول أول كومنت كان.
Learner A6: جراوند نفسها نخليها كلها.
Learner A4: تبقى بيضاء خالص وعندك عايزك كلام مر
Learner A4: السكريب نفسه او الشاشة اللي طالعة تبقى
Learner A4: يعني مثلا ماشي اللوجوز دي كويسة الكلام ده كله كويس بس هي مش عايزة كل حاجة تطلع من أول مرة هي عايزاها زي ما هي في الفيديو كدا فاهم قصدي يعني إنت عندك هنا في الأول خالص نزل وبدأ يشرح
Learner A4: وبعد كده نزل في اللي بعدها إدالك صورة وبدأ يشرف.
Learner A3: إنت موجود.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: سين صح يعني وبعد كده السين.
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A4: ده. المفروض
Learner A4: ميش.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: ليش.
Learner A4: قالت لك ننزل كدا وننزل كدا ماشي لبعدها اللي بعدها كل حاجة يعني بتتشرح واحدة واحدة.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: فاكرين فاكرين عارفينها يا جماعة الفيديوز اللي كانت بتطلع أتوقع كل 1 فينا شافها بيبقى في ريم كده مثلا بتشوفها بيبقى مثلا بيشرح حاجة معينة بتمسك الورقة والقلم وتبدأ تكتب وتبدأ تتفرج.
Learner A6: طيب.
Learner A4: عارف الفيديوهات دي هي عين المرأة.
Learner A4: شرم الشيخ.
Learner A4: المشكلة مش معاي حاجة ليها كان في كان في ويب سايت أنا كنت بستخدمه زمان في المدرسة كان بيعمل الحاجات دي.
Learner A4: طب.
Learner A4: يعني
Learner A4: هو بياخد التوبيك وحده واحده يعني مثلا جينا مثلا بتاع الفيديو هتلاقي في اول فيديو خالص صورة وطالعة زي بتاعة.
Learner A4: ماشي انت قصدك زي الفيديو ده يعني.
Learner A4: بالظبط كده هي عايزة حاجة بالضبط كده.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A4: تمام يعني.
Learner A4: حرفان.
Learner A4: مثلا
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: ما والبتعدة.
Learner A4: ، احنا كنا فين كنا هنا.
Learner A4: ، لا، مش فهمت ما فينا.
Learner A4: علقت على حتة الأساس والكلام ده ولا.
Learner A4: لا الأسد طلعت طلعت تمام بس أنا مش هي المفروض الأسس دي تبقى صور وحاجات كده صح؟
Learner A6: المفروضة.
Learner A4: أنا فاهمه
Learner A4: فأصل أنا ما شفتش أي حاجة فهو ممكن يكون عندي مشكلة في إنت لو إنت.
Learner A4: هو أنا ما تقليش صور يعني لحد دلوقتي ال تويتر بيطلعلي كونسبت.
Learner A4: كونسورز دوت لونغ كونسكو.
Learner A4: يعني
Learner A4: أنا بقوله.
Learner A4: هقول لك أجيب أول ما فتش ال
Learner A4: هو انا المفروض اعمل موريت دلوقتي صح؟
Learner A4: أنت آخر.
Learner A4: شوف اعمل الاول اعمل الاول كل الكومنتس اللي احنا عملناها
Learner A4: خلي يعني ال كود بتاعك قضيتي وبعد كده أعمل مرجع على مين.
Learner A4: ثانية وحدة شو ما بيشي هو في اللي هو اسمه ده.
Learner A4: أيوه هو عامل على انت انت مكاري الداتا بينز على سوبر بينز.
Learner A4: مفروم.
Learner A4: انت عمال البتاع بتعتي بتعمل ما المفروض تبقى على السوفبيت بتاعتي.
Learner A4: انت.
Learner A4: بص دي المفروض ال.
Learner A4: انت كنت واعت لنا الكلام ده.
Learner A4: لا بس كل لما كنت بتكلم في الحوار ما حدش؟ كان بيدي كومانة.
Learner A4: ا.
Learner A4: هو أنت المفروض.
Learner A4: معك إزاي طيب.
Learner A4: فيرومنت فايل فين بصي حقولك أقولك.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: خذ ده عندك ده الدوت إم ده المفروض اللي انت تستخدمه
Learner A4: ولو عايز ال خد الكلام ده كريم شوت كده.
Learner A4: ما هو البامبك كده كرموكست شوية.
Learner A4: طيب الكلام ده في الخاتة. اهو.
Learner A4: ولا ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: أم و.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A4: ده عندي ما فيش غير غير كيوس.
Learner A4: الكلام ده على اللي عندك واللي عايز لينك كل حاجة عندي على الدات دي وادي عندك ده الباسورد
Learner A4: بتاع البيت لو هو طلبه
Learner A4: ممكن ما يطلبوش برضه يا أسامة ومصطفى خود الكلام ده عندكوا عشان لو في حاجة تتخزن، فهي المفروض ان هي تتخزن عندك.
Learner A4: هو.
Learner A4: انت بعتت حطه في.
Learner A4: أيوة ده وانت داخل بقى على.
Learner A4: الباسو ماشي طبعا مساعدته في الراي.
Learner A4: مش أحطو في يعني.
Learner A4: الباسورد ده.
Learner A4: أكيد مش حطي.
Learner A4: الباسورد اللي تحت خالص. ما هو مالوش لزمة
Learner A4: بس انت الكلام ده بيتحط في دوت دي
Learner A4: انت كده كده لما تيجي تعمل بوش على المين أو تعمل ميرج هما بيخشوا أي حاجة في الدوت ين بي.
Learner A4: ما أنا سؤالي فحم.
Learner A4: تحطه فين.
Learner A4: شو رأيك.
Learner A4: ما يا عم لا اقولك عشان لما تيجي تستخدمه لو هو طلب منك بحطه.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام معايا يا أسامة.
Learner A6: معاكم.
Learner A4: فاحنا كده أول حاجة خالص إحنا عايزين نثبت إنفلات هنا في عادي بيضة
Learner A4: تمام العب باف لأن زي ما انت عايز يعني مش الورا ده أنا شايفو في السويت بصراحة والحاجات اللي هنا الكلام ده أنا شايفه حلو قوي بس هو محتاج تقسيمة بس ومش كل حاجة تطلع مرة وحدة
Learner A4: انت مثلا انت جيت هنا وقلت انتو ما عرفش إيه مثلا تشرح بعد كده آخر حاجة فاهم قصدي.
Learner A6: اي طبعا.
Learner A4: بس دفت سوبر من الكومنت اللي هي قالتها
Learner A4: عايزة حاجة برضه يعني الكلام ده إلى حد ما قريب من اللي هي عايزاه.
Learner A6: طب تمام بس.
Learner A4: صيدلية.
Learner A6: صح.
Learner A4: ده اللي كنت بعته اهو.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: بس ده المفروض اللي تالي يعني مبارح
Learner A4: فهو أنا عايز تعمل حاجة أسامة موصوف حيقولك خود الفايل بتاع الوركستر بتاعي تمام اللي هو الفايل ده.
Learner A6: لون.
Learner A4: ده تمام.
Learner A6: الله يرحمه.
Learner A4: يعني إزاي الكلام اللي هنا ده هيطلع وانت بناء عليه تحولوا ده.
Learner A6: أستخدمها لشو.
Learner A4: إزاي إزاي. أنت تقدر تعمل منه.
Learner A6: والله هو.
Learner A4: انت المفروض عندك هفهمك بس الميكانيزم بتاعه لما تاخد الكود بتاعي أنا المفروض أعمل ميرجي يعني أخلص بس الحاجات اللي أنا دي واول ما انا اخلص هبعتلك الميرج.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: في الدستور.
Learner A4: هتفتحش عادي على الفايل نفسه عادي وتكتب الكوماند ده
Learner A4: هو عامة حيقولك يعني هو بيبقى يو بي يوفي كور يوفي كورن.
Learner A6: طيفي.
Learner A4: وتشغل برضو الفرونتان وخش حاول توصل لفيديو قول له ده اللي بيطلع لي
Learner A4: إزاي أقدر منه ازاي اقدر اعمل منه
Learner A4: يعني اقول له هي كده خلصانة ولو في كومنت برضو ادهالك ابعتهالي عادي منزبطها مع بعض.
Learner A4: يعني في حاجة ما أعرفش إنتوا بس لحد فيكم حاطط الإكستنشن بتاع أي حديث على فيسكو انتبهوا.
Learner A4: أيه.
Learner A4: ليل لو أنت كود.
Learner A4: ممكن تخلي يعني اللي كانت فرح بعتها في الأول ماشي.
Learner A6: هو في البداية خالص.
Learner A4: اللي هو.
Learner A4: بتقولوا
Learner A4: الفايل لو دي.
Learner A4: مال.
Learner A4: دوت ام ديفايل وحطيتو جوا فيسكو وليلا موديل حطوا جوا في سكوت ديفايل
Learner A4: بيقرأ بيقرأ الليلة اللي جوا دي كلها لاقط كل 1 فيكم بيعمل إيه ويتعامل على.
Learner A6: هو في مشكلة بس في بي ار دي ده إنه هو إحنا حاليا مناش ماشيين عليه يعني ده مش في البداية المطلوب
Learner A6: ده يبقى في احسن حاجات متساقطت.
Learner A4: دي نو.
Learner A4: أنا أنا واخذ الفايل ده واخذ الفايل عمر حط.
Learner A4: ما هو الفايل اللي برضه الفايل اللي أنا بعته بناء على التقسيمة القديمة مبدئيا مثلا.
Learner A6: دي.
Learner A4: يعني انت مثلا احمد عيد كان ماسك
Learner A4: ما عملتش ال سكريبت وأنا اللي عملت ال سكريبت
Learner A4: معرفش يوسف كان ماسك ال ريندر والأنيميشن
Learner A4: اسامة بقى هو اللي ماسك بحكم بالزبط فين.
Learner A4: ماشي هو عامة مين ماسك إيه هو كمسميات مش عارف إيه ده بيعمل كذا ده.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A4: انلقط.
Learner A4: عايز بس توضح نقطة إيه هو السكوب بتاعنا أو هو بتاعنا حاليا إحنا الميندي بتاعنا حاليا.
Learner A4: زيادة غير
Learner A4: بتاعنا حاليا اللي إحنا اللي هي بتاعتك المفروض الأسس اللي انت بتعمله بيطلع أسست ده المفروض اللي هو بيخزن الكلام ده في داتابيز أو شوف الميكانيزم بتاعه يبقى لو حيبقى مثلا داتا وهتنبعت ليه
Learner A4: بناء على حيبدأ يحولها فيجوان
Learner A4: تمام حابب أو شايف اللي هو ممكن يعمل أتس دي. تتخزن في واحنا نبقى نعملها من من برضه ما فيش مشكلة المهم يعني اللي انت تعرفه إن معدش في حاجة اسمها كومبوزيشن ولا ريندر ولا أنيميشن الكلام ده كله بدأ
Learner A4: أو حيبقى في أو في البرونتين
Learner A4: فالباقي مهمته بتوقف عند اليس جينديشن.
Learner A4: معلش عشان الواحد في.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: عرف.
Learner A4: على سيركل عشان.
Learner A4: الكلام ده ما بس ماشي لا ما طألش على توتر.
Learner A4: هو انت في يعني انت كنت ساعات لما بتعمل حاجة بتقول لنا أو في حاجات بتقولها عشان نمشي كلنا.
Learner A4: أيوة. لا، لا، أنا قصدي الأبروتش الجديد ما سألش على فكرة عم بقولك 100,000 بس.
Learner A4: هذا صحيح.
Learner A4: اللي.
Learner A4: أنت طول الكلام ده على.
Learner A4: طبعا أقدر أقوله بس هي الفكرة اللي حاليا أنا مش قادر لأن أنا مش نام كويس.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي شغلك حالا يعني بقولك عن مصر.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي.
Learner A4: إحنا كودنغ يعني.
Learner A4: دي حقيقة فعلا وبدأت ضدي اشتغل انتي جرافتين المشكلة.
Learner A4: عايز.
Learner A4: مطلع لي حاجة كده.
Learner A6: أنا.
Learner A4: أشتغل بيه بصراحة.
Learner A4: أنا أنا بصلي انت شايف كمية اللورز. تمام.
Learner A6: بس أنت جابتي.
Learner A4: مش عارف ليه.
Learner A6: على كده.
Learner A4: طيب هي عايز أنا.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: هي عايزانا نفكش حاجة قبل ما نمرش سبرينتو.
Learner A4: انت لو انت خلصت بتاعتك لا خلاص.
Learner A4: ، طب خلاص.
Learner A4: طلعت.
Learner A4: خليني أصلا ديون ريتر أنا جاي جاي. أعمل يعني للشغل
Learner A4: لقيته شغال كل ده مين برنش مش على برنش بتاعي.
Learner A4: إيه.
Learner A4: بس سويتش
Learner A4: بالحاجات اللي تغيرت أصلا لقيتها راحت كلها. أنا كنت عامل 14 تشانج لقيت تشينج 1 بس راجع معايا
Learner A4: عملت كل حاجة بس ما نقش حاجة.
Learner A4: سعيتيلي رعايت تانيين.
Learner A6: لا، لا.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A4: أنا تقريبا.
Learner A4: فمن ساعتها بصراحة، أنا بكون مت على أي حاجة ولا بكومت على طول.
Learner A4: انت ، خليك أو إعملكم على الأقل عندك على البرنتس فاهم بحيث إن إنت تقدر ترجع لها.
Learner A4: ما هي النقطة إن أنا كنت ناسي إن أنا أعلم مين مش عالبرانشي بتاعي.
Learner A4: أنا كنت على مين كنت بس هي دي المشكلة اللي حصلت.
Learner A4: فلما جيت سويتش الحاجة راحت.
Learner A4: بينست.
Learner A4: لا، ما هو الحمد لله سترت وأحمد بسرعة. قالولي تمام ماشي.
Learner A4: ,
Learner A4: ربما.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A4: يا رب دي تبع الخل.
Learner A4: طيب هوندا في اللحمة قالوليهولي التذكرة المقطوعة كل 1 يعمل فا
Learner A4: ولو في جديد بقى انت لما تسحب كده يبقى لونين براحتك يعني.
Learner A4: ماشي هو تمام أنا بس كان يعني غول بتاعي كان في المتينغ ده اللي هو وضح وعلق على حوار
Learner A4: اللي حاسس هو هو يعني هو دور كبير يعني.
Learner A4: ما أنا مش فاهم ولا صور وكده ولا هو.
Learner A6: هو المفروض إن هو أنا دلوقتي أساسا اللي بيحصل عندي إن أنا دلوقتي إيه من نفسه اللي أنا بديهوله أنا بقوله إنه إنت عايزك تعملي كامبليت
Learner A6: وفي أسيت أجينت أنا عملت كده هوت يعني اللي هو إي يعني بس
Learner A6: ده مش بيعمل أسست كاملة في أسست اللي هي اتش تي تي بي اللي هو صورة كده عن النت
Learner A6: هو كل اللي بيعملوا. إنه بيقدر يختار الصورة الصح بناء على الحاجة يعني إنت لو دخلت مثلا لوغو دوك
Learner A6: لوغو دوكر دا هو اتش بي فايف
Learner A6: هو كل اللي بعمله. أنا إن أنا بفهم تعمل إزاي وبناء عليه ببدأ أحطله أسست كده هوت وهو يستخدم أسيت ال أوي دي ده يعني أو اللينك دوة
Learner A6: فأنا مش عارف بقى هل المفروض كمان يطلعلي صورة
Learner A6: وبناء على ال ديسكريبشن بتاع الصورة ده أنا بستخدمه عادي ولا لأ
Learner A6: لأن ده اللي أنا قدامي ده اللي أنا كنت.
Learner A4: الله.
Learner A6: البداية.
Learner A4: فأنا شايف إن المفروض الكلام ده يبقى بناء على اسس لان الصورة دي أسست.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: إيماج نفسها. المفروض دي اس.
Learner A4: فالمفروض اللي هي تبقى طالعة جيمريتيد من من عمر وانت تخش تاخدها على طول فاهم.
Learner A4: ما هو المفروض الاقي مثلا عشان كدا فانا مفروض أعمله ترانج لثور ولا.
Learner A4: لا، لا، لا، لا، لا.
Learner A6: كل الكلام ده إزاي.
Learner A4: لا، لا.
Learner A6: في الكلام ده.
Learner A4: بالضبط بالضبط.
Learner A6: سيفكر.
Learner A4: موضوع في حتة وعملية.
Learner A4: في إعطاء مني من عشان أحمد كان بعتهالي
Learner A4: هو مصطفى مش عارف المهماتيف تو جيمناوي
Learner A4: دبي فاس كوتشنز أند إمبروف كورتي
Learner A4: هل المفروض أستعمل آي ثاني يرجى هنا؟ مسؤولين.
Learner A4: ممكن علشان تحمل كمية. صور اللي هتطلع انت كده بتخلص الكوتا فاهم.
Learner A4: هو أنا عندي دخل بعيد الجماعة، فأنا عندي يعني.
Learner A6: و
Learner A6: أنت جربتي غير ال إي بي آي نفسه الإ بي آي إنت كده كده حتى يعني أنا معاي الأكاونت دوت الأكاونت بتاعي على الجامعة كده.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A6: ريتير عادي فأنت لما كومبرتير زي الفكرة كلها إن إنت طول ما انت في الفريتر
Learner A6: أول ما هتزود كتير بقى حتبدأ عشان تزود كتير هي دي وش كدة لازم تدفع مش حيكملك خالص.
Learner A4: عشان تبقى فاهم معلش أقاطعك هو أنا أنا فاهم فكرة أنا فاهم فكرة بس أنا عمري ما اشتغلت إف بي آي.
Learner A4: ضروري.
Learner A4: خالد ولادي أسأ.
Learner A4: ولا بصي حوريك حاجة دلوقتي عندك هوات فين الاستوديو لا لا سلمين أيوة 60
Learner A4: جول الاستوديو ده المفروض اللي انت بتاخد منو بتاعك تمام.
Learner A4: مع إمبورت المفروض صح؟
Learner A4: ما أنت دلوقتي.
Learner A4: فروم كذا ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام بصي مثلا دلوقتي ده كان بروجكت بتاع بلوك شين
Learner A4: كنت شغال عليه، فهو طبعا الكوتة خلينا نخش على خش على.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام انا استخدمتو بس عشان بس
Learner A4: خلاص ماشي وانا المفروض اللي أنا عندي جيمناوي
Learner A4: انليميتد يعني المفروض لو أنا داخل بمالك جامع بطيف منك ثاني أنت شايفاي.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A4: معايا قالت لي حاول حاول تعمله
Learner A4: اللي هو نشوف ونبعتهولها والكلام ده.
Learner A4: النجف إيه.
Learner A4: وأنا بعتبارها المشكلة كتيرة جدا.
Learner A6: صور ببلاشي يعني.
Learner A4: كمال.
Learner A6: بيديك صور.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A6: لأ هو الفيديو حيبقى الفيديو ده أساسا هو كل اللي حيعملو إنت لو جبت أي موديل عادي خالص هو حيطلعولك هو بس انت محتاج نموذج كويس في.
Learner A4: أوه.
Learner A6: كل ال ديزاين اللي انت محتاجه.
Learner A4: طيب.
Learner A4: في نقطة كان أحمد قالها لنا على
Learner A4: أو كان كان تقريبا كان هو بعتلنا.
Learner A6: ال.
Learner A4: إي بي أوي كده.
Learner A4: الله يطول عمرك.
Learner A4: أي شك.
Learner A4: بشكل لايتعمل أوبن راوتر او حاجة.
Learner A4: ما أنا ضربته في الروتر وفي الروتر، استخدمته كان شغال تمام بس هولي برايسنج برضه.
Learner A6: ليميت أو ليميت بتاعه قليل.
Learner A4: طب ما هو مفروض يدونا الكومندا ويدونا أي حاجة.
Learner A4: ما دلنا يعني لان الشغل بتاعنا كله شغال كل إيجن عبارة عن.
Learner A6: وكمان إنت مش شغال.
Learner A4: يعني شغالة وإنت شغال في شركة.
Learner A4: طيب بيدولك كل حاجة وهم عندهم.
Learner A4: فيعني معرفش حتة حتة إن إحنا نشتريك في معرفش بصراحة.
Learner A4: والله ما أعرفش ما اعرفش.
Learner A4: أو ممكن نبقى فاهمين غلط الله اعلم ولا هي قالت كده.
Learner A4: هو لا يا ليالي طب ممكن تشوفوا سوا لو تعملوا سيرت بعيد ممكن تشوفوا كده
Learner A4: و قالتلي ماشي في حاجة لوكال سيرش الاول احسن حاجة في كودنغ مثلا أو كده شوفوا وين برضو هيجس.
Learner A4: عشان إميزة طيب.
Learner A4: والكودنغ انت طالما انت طالما هتعمل للكلام دة كلو اتش ميل فأنت شغال
Learner A4: إحنا الستة اللي احنا شغالين بيها انت عندك ويب جي ال عندك دوم وعندك حاجة تالتة كانت ريموشن
Learner A4: رموشك الجديدة المفروض يعني أحاول أعمل عشان تخلي الويب مورين يعني بدلا.
Learner A4: مشكلتنا.
Learner A4: 20.
Learner A4: فايز عامة. معلش كمل.
Learner A4: بدل ما انت بدل ما عادي يعني
Learner A4: بدل ما انت تبقى داخل كده ما تقدرش. انت توقف متقدرش ترجع لورا ما تقدرش توقف على أي حاجة. ريموشن بيحل بقى الكلام دا
Learner A4: غير كل ده وده انت ما معندكش داونلود.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: فالمفروض ريموتن بحل الكلام ده.
Learner A4: إيه اللي.
Learner A4: أو تكنيك عامل زي رياكتي بالضبط إسمه ريمو
Learner A4: يعني أنا وسامح اني اشتغلت بيها يعني.
Learner A4: سؤال إحنا مشكلتنا في الكتب بس صح.
Learner A4: إحنا مشكلتنا
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A4: بشكل عام.
Learner A4: يا منين.
Learner A4: لو.
Learner A4: السلام عليكم.
Learner A4: على أحسن فرنش.
Learner A4: ما هو إحنا ممكن بتاع ده لا لا موطن سورس
Learner A4: تمام هو مش حيبقى في مشكلة بس ده معناه اللي احنا يعني كل 1 فينا حينزله عنده.
Learner A4: أما ولا
Learner A6: ما أتوقعش
Learner A6: بص هو فكرة إن إنت دلوقتي تقدر تنزل الموديل نفسه وتستخدمه بنفسك خالص بس فكرة نفسها لأن إنت دلوقتي عشان يكون أوبن شيرس فديك سيك مثلا لو حتستخدم اللي هو دي فور فلاش تقريبا إسمه فده مش فاكر كم 1,000,000,000 برمته ده مستحيل يشتغل.
Learner A4: بن سعيد.
Learner A6: يعني انت محتاجه.
Learner A4: انت اقل حاجة عندك فيسبليون يعني.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A4: اتجهت.
Learner A6: حاجة زي كده
Learner A6: مش شاغل حاجة زي كده انت بتحتاج دلوقتي جوبايدر بيديك هو جي بيو وشغال عنده و بيديك هو ال إي بي آي
Learner A6: فعش.
Learner A4: سو هافينج.
Learner A6: هيديك فلوس.
Learner A4: الكلام.
Learner A6: تقريبا بيدي برضه حاجات زي كده بس مش عارف آخر حاجة سمعتها. إنه بيقولوا توقف في مسرح مش عارف.
Learner A4: بقولك إيه أنا مبارح وانا بحاول أعمل مصطفى
Learner A4: يعني من ضمن التلات ساعات اللي أنا كنت عايز شغال فيهم كان في ساعة ساعتين ونص قاعد بجرب انت في مصر فمحظور عندك الموديل.
Learner A6: الفيس والفيديو.
Learner A4: عم نشتغل.
Learner A6: كويسة جدا يعني بتديك على فكرة كويسة جدا بس الفيديو محظورة في مصر برضه ما تشتغلش في مصر
Learner A6: فيعني اهلا بك في مصر.
Learner A4: والكمتونيزو فويلا نتعرف على أي.
Learner A6: فعلا.
Learner A4: بالله.
Learner A6: إنت عارف إنه حرفيا احنا كنا عاملين مشروع تخرج بيه يعني حاليا تقريبا البتاع وقف كده.
Learner A4: ده مو لسه ممكن ممكن أشوف طاجن كيس ماعرفتش.
Learner A6: هو ممكن.
Learner A4: الله يسلمك.
Learner A6: والله.
Learner A4: وأهم حاجة وصلت.
Learner A6: هو أنا بصلك اللي أنا حعمله حاليا بالظبط عشان تبقوا إيه برضه مواصلين معايا.
Learner A4: ولا.
Learner A6: أنا دلوقتي يعني مش حالا بصراحة أوي لأني برضه انا ممكن انام شوية.
Learner A4: حلوه ايوه.
Learner A6: إيه بس لأنا حعمله اننا اخد دلوقتي كل الأوركسترا بدك تعمله.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A6: أيوا أخذه الأول وأتأكد اللي طالع عشان أعرف هو ده اللي حاستخدمو هستخدمه ازاي يعني.
Learner A4: تمام يعني خذ بقى واعملوا بروجين عن.
Learner A6: الخطوط.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: إن أنا دي الوقت إزاي لأن هي برضه يعني بتقول لنا إن إنت حاجات تعملها وخلاص أنا ما ليش تدخل في بسبب النقطة.
Learner A4: ما هي،
Learner A4: قولوا قولوا.
Learner A6: هو بياخد ال سيستم روم. ده وبناء عليه، بحاول يعملك الثلج.
Learner A6: وبعدما.
Learner A4: هو.
Learner A6: يبدأ بقى يعملك أسيتس للتنبلة.
Learner A4: ما هو إحنا المفروض بقى اللي احنا حنعمله المفروض بقى اللي احنا حنعملوا
Learner A4: المفروض يعني لو بي اي ضبط حيبقى عامل حاجة خفيفة برضه لو هو ضبط هيبقى في إيماجيز حتبقى متزنة برضه خصوبة بيه هو المفروض يعني من واقع خبرتي أنا في الشغل الكلام ده
Learner A4: اللي هو الكلام ده كله كميتا داتا وبناء على يطلع
Learner A4: محطوط فيه الينكس الكلام ده يعني هو انت مثلا يعني تعملك ازاي انت اشتغلت قبل كده.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A6: شوية.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A4: فاهميني حاجة ولا أنا خلاص كده.
Learner A4: انت كمان متأكد بس يعني اللي عندك دي يعني يا ريت تبدأ يعني الحوار يبدأ يطلع معاك ثور بجد.
Learner A4: مش يعني تنام وابعت لنا الكومنتات اللي عندك يعني.
Learner A4: أنا عامة. ما عنديش مشكلة ممكن ندخل ميدينغ بالليل ما عنديش مشكلة.
Learner A4: شكرا ساعات التوجيهات عجوب بتاع شركة بس.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: حاجات تدخل طولها. دي.
Learner A4: ماشي هو صح يا جماعة عشان أنا نسيت أقلكوا المفروض اللي إحنا عندنا الديمو داي قالوا لي أبلغكوا يعني ونبدأ نحضر ال بريزنتيشن.
Learner A6: هو يمتى بإذن الله ولا مالوش.
Learner A4: هو بيقولوا في نص تمانية.
Learner A6: حلو إن شاء الله.
Learner A6: هو حيكون عندهم في الشركة صح.
Learner A4: هو كلامك جيد.
Learner A4: هم لسا مش متأكدين هو حيبقى فيزيكل ولا لأ بس هو شهور كده لو هو فيزيكال وإنت ما عرفتش تيجي عادي يعني ممكن تحضر أونلاين
Learner A4: حايد.
Learner A6: لا، هو أنا عادي هو لو في لو فيزيك في الجيزة والقاهرة فأنا كده كده هنا يعني أعرف أقدر إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: بتشربون حتوكل. أنا.
Learner A4: ماشي تمام.
Learner A6: إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: ماشي سلام يا شباب.
Learner A4: لا، لا اسامة. انا قلت محتاجين عدة روان.
Learner A4: انا وانت محتاجين قعدة روائح.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: كان مزبط.
Learner A6: لأن أنا شافني رؤو تضبطوا تزبيطة كاملة يبقى خلص زي الفل.
Learner A4: ، انت ممكن نخش مع بعض امتى.
Learner A6: بص انا النهارده يعني
Learner A6: أنا حقولك عموما الأسبوع ده على الأقل بس عشان يعني في في كورس ثاني كده هو الأسبوع دوة الميعاد. ما توقعتش بصراحة، إني أتقابل فيه يعني
Learner A6: ليلة الضغط الاسبوع ده وبيبقى دائما من 10 لاربعة هيبقى الاسبوع ده بس يعني.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Learner A6: فأنا قبل 4 مش موجود.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A6: فأنا ممكن يعني معاك في أي وقت ممكن مثلا الساعة احدعشر أو حاجة.
Learner A4: بالليل. صح.
Learner A4: فول. الفل نعم.
Learner A6: كده.
Learner A4: هو أنا كده أسأل يعني.
Learner A6: طيب ماشي هو أنا بسهر بس يعني شايف بصراحة مش على للاف يعني مجرد تيجي الساعة تناشر أنا بكون مقفل بكون انفصلت تماما مابعرفش أفكر خالص.
Learner A4: ما أنا أحب.
Learner A6: إن يحصل حاجة لو حصل حاجة أنا وقتها أقدر أفتح معاك لو في حاجة نقلها عادي.
Learner A4: لا، أنا عايز بس نخش.
Learner A6: نعم.
Learner A4: أنا عايز أخش فورم كدا على نحط بلان.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: و.
Learner A6: طيب
Learner A6: النهاردة مثلا لو على لو لو على 10 أو حداشر نخش شوية كده ونعمل بلان نظبط فيها الدنيا وبعدها نقفل.
Learner A4: ماشي تمام حلو.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: أعود.
Learner A6: دلوقتي أزبط كم حاجة كده بحيث يبقى داخل
Learner A6: خدت اللي هو فعلا الحاجات اللي احنا عارفينها عشان نبقى عارفين حنعرف نكمل ولا لأ عرفنا نكمل مية وحنحط البلان ونبدا نكمل بإذن الله.
Learner A4: خل.
Learner A6: تمام بيجي خلاص حداشر.
Learner A4: ، تمام، تمام ما فيش مشكلة.
Learner A6: خلاص بإذن الله.
Learner A3: رجالة الميعاد.
Learner A4: هو انا خش انا وسامع علشان لو عايز تجويني.
Learner A3: ده إمتى دلوقتي.
Learner A4: لا على حداشر بالليل كده.
Learner A3: ماشي حضرتك بالليل ممكن ادخلوا عادي من على سيركب صح.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A3: على.
Learner A4: ما عرفش ممكن.
Learner A3: يعني ممكن تبعتلي برايفات على الشركة.
Learner A4: أول شي.
Learner A3: خلاص عزيز.
Learner A6: تعملوا غوغل ميت بقى عشان.
Learner A4: النقد. رحلة التمثيل.
Learner A6: من أكاونت الجامعة الأكاونت الجامعة بيديك أنظمة على غوغل ميل.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: دموعوية.
Learner A6: إن شاء الله ما نطولش للدرجة دي بإذن الله.
Learner A4: لا ان شاء الله إن شاء الله بس كل 1 فينا هيبقى فاق شوية الدنيا تبقى أحسن بإذن الله.
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: رجالك.
Learner A4: ماشي شباب حاجة.
Learner A6: حبيبي السلام عليكم.